welcome to the heavy spoiler show i'm
your host paul
aka the guy whose puns always crease
people up with a crap sense of humor
and this video we're breaking down 75
easter eggs in koba kai
obviously full spoilers ahead here so if
you weren't one of the seven
billion people to binge watch this in
one day then i highly recommend that you
turn off now
make sure you subscribe to the channel
for videos like this each and every day
and please show some mercy by clicking
the thumbs up button
without the way thank you for clicking
this now let's get into the breakdown
okay so the season opens with a news
report that talks about the fight at all
valley high from the ending of season 2.
in it we see a character known as
leonard johnson being interviewed
and he says that he thought karate died
out in the 80s
this is a fourth wall breaking comment
as karate kid was popular during the 80s
and it's seen a revival in recent years
because of this show
cut to johnny in a bar and he ends up
having an argument with two guys
and this makes him punch through one of
their car windows everyone's favorite
nice guy and staple of society john
crees
actually did something similar in karate
kid 2 when trying to attack mr miyagi
the next school easter egg happens when
daniel goes to the school parents
teacher conference
during it the parents and panel are
slamming karate
and when daniel tries to defend it a
voice comes in and says
i heard you were the real bully this is
actually the voice of cobra kaiko
created your shield
i think it's playing up the fan theory
that basically says that dany was the
bully
this has been online for a couple of
years now and it's seen as something
that inspired the show to tackle
a lot of the themes that it did in the
first season now whether you agree with
that or not
daniel was definitely bullied in high
school and at one point the cobra gang
wore skeleton costumes tori also done's
a skeleton hoodie throughout the season
showing thematically that she is very
much taking on the position of johnny
while sam takes on dany's huge shout
outs to superhero nexus for sending me
that
and i think it just laces the show with
a lot more subtext
amanda actually calls tori freddy
krueger and this is because in that
final fight
she of course used claws after johnny is
arrested he's taken to a cell
where a man shows him his foot and asks
if it looks infected
this might be a reach but i think it's a
nod to some 41 who made an album of the
same name
the band of big karate kid fans and even
tweeted ones that ralph macchio better
return for the reboot
jump to daniel journey into cobra kai
and we see a sign that says
fear does not exist in this dojo kris
actually said this to his students in
the first film
and it's very much a mantra of how he
sees things there's also a cardboard
cutout of the character
which i think is sort of playing on the
one that was present in the first movie
kris also tries to mess with daniel's
mind a bit by saying that he doesn't
blame robbie for the fight
as there's no such thing as a bad
student mr miyagi used to say that
there's no such thing as a bad student
only a bad teacher
and daniel has also uttered this
throughout the season showing just how
well that crease knows his enemies
daniel says he's not gonna fight him but
crease says it's inevitable
and this could be a play on the fan joke
that creases a cross between thanos and
david hasselhoff
hey there's worse people to be compared
with namely me
now chris also says that he will finish
it and though this might
again be a bit of a reach it could be a
call back to him telling johnny to
finish daniel at the end of the first
movie
this is of course something that never
happened and it's led to this decade
spanning rivalry that's ruined
everyone's lives
but it's made netflix a lot better let's
be honest now in the opening of episode
2 we catch a bully arriving at a diner
with his friends
he says his car is a piece of junk and
that he's going to get rid of it
and of course this would end up becoming
mr miyagi's
now this bully is deliberately put in
place to make you think that it's a
young john crease
to make this even more apparent the
bully is actually played by jesse covey
aka martin covey's son now the car
appears throughout the series and during
episode 3
daniel talks about how it was a present
from mr miyagi
this is a good example of art imitating
life as
the studio actually gave ralph the call
when filming wrapped
this bully tells his friend that you
can't show people mercy
and is of course a mantra that crease
would adopt making the misdirect
even more misdirectional if that's even
a word
now when fighting them outside crease
sweeps one of the gang's legs
and this is something that he would tell
johnny to do in karate kid1
this sweep the leg tactic is later used
at the church
when johnny goes to see his old buddy
opal
episode 3 is called now you're gonna pay
which is what johnny said to daniel
during the skeleton halloween fight that
the tory hoodie links back to
we catch robbie reading lord of the
flies and this book is basically about a
gang of kids creating a new society in
which they have certain rules in order
the kids are pretty much running amok at
all valley high
so maybe this is a reference to that now
johnny goes to a job interview
and has to admit to assaulting miners
which is of course a nod to his fight in
the first
season during which he saved miguel jump
to episode 4
and we see the kobra kai kids trying to
kick a bonsai tree off the top of a post
though hawk gets around this bonsai
trees are of course synonymous with mr
miyagi
so kris getting them to do this further
hammers home that miyagido and daniel
are the enemy
hawk also does some football tricks
which are very similar to what daniel
did in the first film
this idea of football and and yeah i'm
calling it that and not soccer
don't at me is laced throughout the
episode and it even leads to a big fight
on the pitch
which further ties back to this easter
egg cobra kai also show up on motorbikes
at the fundraiser
and this could be a nod to how they
arrived on the beach in the first film
daniel also reunites with an old flame
who says that many tried to marry her
but none of them fought to the death
which is of course a reference to the
fight that we see playing out in
flashbacks
the pair go for a drink and you might
notice the ice cube holder which looks
very similar to the ice blocks that
daniel had to break in karate kid 2.
now this bit kind of segues across
episode 4 and 5
and greece visits robbie and calls him
son i really wish he was my dad
however he does tell him about his real
father namely the time he drew a kid
named vidal at the old valley
vidal won the 1981 tournament but from
that point onward
cobra kai dominated this is actually
part of the law that led up to the first
film
and the actor behind vidal is credited
with coming up with the crane technique
this martial arts master even doubled
for mr miyagi at points during the film
so it's great that they're still giving
him little nods here and there
chris tells robbie that the mumbo jumbo
mr miyagi teaches
might score on some points in the
tournament but that it's completely
useless when used in real life
as we know from the films cobra kai were
big bullies outside of the ring
and used to be a lot of people up
however dany managed to beat them in the
tournament
which does kind of solidify that creases
sort of telling the truth here
episode 4 and 5 has a return of the
villain chosen
but he becomes a good guy and actually
tells daniel about the secrets to the
pressure point technique
which is something that is laced
throughout karate i kind of feel like
this is going to end up becoming the key
to defeat increasing karbaka in season 4
but obviously let me know below if you
have any other theories
daniel also uncovers a document that
details the crane technique
which is something that of course popped
up time and time again in the franchise
now you might notice that in these
flashbacks a little one-handed drum is
used
and miguel actually picks one of these
up at miyagi doe in episode nine
chozin gets danny back for honking his
nose in the kill moment
and it's a hilarious little callback
even if you haven't seen the original
there's also the 1988 swimsuit edition
which no doubt got johnny through some
lonely nights without
ali you might want we might not want to
read that if the pages are stuck
together miguel now during the fun house
fight
hawk breaks yes he breaks dimitri's arm
now it's pretty brutal and this is
actually riffing on the miguel and
robbie fight from the end of season 2.
miguel could have done it but instead he
let robbie go
which led to him getting kicked over the
railing hawk
doesn't leave anything to chance and he
breaks dimitri's arm
showing what could have happened to
robbie had miguel have not been such a
nice guy
now at the end of the episode we also
see a return of the sign fear does not
exist in this dojo
when amanda goes to kobakai she calls
chris rambo
and carvey was actually in rambo first
blood part two
so this is a nice little nod to his
prior work greece also says
i'll like that which is something that
he did in the first film
in episode 6 we also see miguel's
rehabilitation
and to me this is sort of riffing on the
real life story of bruce lee
in 1969 bruce injured his back because
he didn't warm up properly
this caused a lot of nerve damage and he
was actually told he could never
practice martial arts again
however lee healed and over time he went
on to have the massive career
that we all know him for this journey is
of course very similar to the one that
miguel travels on
so i think they're kind of hinting here
where things could possibly go in the
future
we also catch danny and sam out fishing
and they talk about the time that sam
lin balance
this is a reference to a similar scene
in the first film when mr miyagi took
dany out in a boat
daniel takes her to where the old valley
tournament is and says that this is
where he almost lost to fear
this is a big reference to the karate
kid 3 which this season is clearly
paying homage to
and i do kind of get the feeling that
it's going to pay off even more in the
next one
now this season itself is actually
littered with the villain from that
namely terry silva and for all those who
are still in doubt whether the soldier
is him or not
he's actually named dropped in the
vietnam scenes i kind of have a theory
that silva actually started to done a
ponytail as a tribute to his fallen
friend
but yeah whether that's true or not i
really don't know but
alongside kris silva was of course one
of the big bads
and mike barnes was their student which
made danny almost lose to fear
not to go off too deep on the fan
theories but there are some that think
tory will be revealed
as being related to silver or bonds but
that still remains to be seen
we also see who krislin martial arts
from and his techniques are actually
repeated in the karate kid
johnny creates eagle fan karate and even
wears a red jacket at one point which
looks very similar to the one that you
wore in the first film
i cut to episode 8 and this entry is
called the good the bad and the badass
which is of course a play on the film
the good the bad and the ugly
hey they can't all be multi-layered
easter eggs yeah just just let me have
some easy ones
now in this daniel says that mr miyagi
used to tell him that if you're looking
for revenge you can start by digging two
graves
not only did the characters say this in
the first film but this saying dates
back to ancient chinese philosopher
confucius
the philosopher is credited with saying
seek revenge and you should dig two
graves
so it's clear this idea of doing things
to get even
are not laced in miyagi's teachings at
all jump to episode 9 titled feel the
night
and this is actually a song from the
soundtrack of the first film
it could be heard in the background of
daniel and ali's first day at golf and
stuff
which is mirrored here when johnny takes
her out you might also remember this
location from the first season
as it's the same place that miguel and
sam went for their first date
before applying to ali we can also see
in johnny's messages that the names
shane keller and mallory young appear
amongst them
shane and mallory are both producers on
kobakai so this is a nice little nod to
the creative team behind the series
ali's parents house is also exactly the
same to how it was in the first movie
but hey who wouldn't want to live there
forever
now not long after sam says it's not
1984 to a dad
and this is a reference to the air of
the first film's release
speaking of that movie johnny admits
that he screwed up
and not only ruined ali's friendship but
also her radio
johnny actually did this in the first
movie and it's one of the reasons that
ali probably ended up with dany radios
weren't cheap back then
now ali also jokes about punching him in
the face which you may remember from the
first film
and hey maybe she was the bully the
whole time
now when miguel meets daniel during this
entry they also discuss
several moments from the first movie
this includes the illegal kick which
danny used on johnny
something that's still up for debate and
his mention of the water hose incident
which of course is another one of
danny's less less friendly moments
maybe he was the buddy after all now
johnny arrives at the country club to
find ally talking to dany
the position of this is very similar to
the first film except that the roles
were reversed with dany being the one
who discovered them
however unlike dany johnny doesn't get
covered in spaghetti
now this is actually referenced in the
next episode in which your waiter almost
spills several bowls over his white suit
this is the first time that danny and
ali have met in several decades
and she says that it's funny that this
is the place the pair bumped into each
other
now episode 10 is called december 19th
and this is the day of the all valley
tournament in the first film
however where is that saw dany and
johnny facing off against each other
this entry sees them joining up at the
end showing that things have come full
circle
throughout the episode hawk wears a red
jacket and this could be a call back to
johnny's
and it does sort of hint at the journey
he goes on in this episode
realizing that kris is the bad guy we
see where chris got the idea of cobras
from
and using them as a symbol could even be
him conquering his fear and deeply
rooted ptsd
the season ends with crease calling what
i presume is silva
but obviously let me know your thoughts
below and whether you agree with me or
not
and you better agree with me or the
bloody mouse gets it anyway
that wraps up our list and i just want
to give a huge shout out to everyone who
commented on our last video and dropped
some of these easter eggs
i know there'll be a ton in this that i
missed so if you spotted some that i
didn't then please drop them in the
comments below
as a thank you for interacting with the
video you'll actually get entered into a
prize draw for a copy of both the hobbit
and lord of the rings 4k box set
which we'll be announcing on the 30th of
january like i said
you just have to make sure you subscribe
to the channel with notifications on
and leave a comment below and hey you
entered into the prize draw
now the winners of last month's
competition are on screen right now
so if that's you then message me on
twitter at heavyspoilers
if you just want to come chat to me then
the links to our socials are in the
description
and you can also support the channel by
clicking the join button as a thank you
you get videos like this early
if you want something else to watch then
make sure you check out our breakdown of
the ending of cobra kai season 3 which
will be linked on screen right now
we go over all the ins and outs of the
series so it's definitely worth checking
out if you have any questions on where
things could be going
without the way thank you for sitting
through the video i've been paul and
i'll see you next time
and remember no mercy strike first
just said
you